brunir sauter réchauffer mijoter cuir à
vapeur apprécions rapide et plus encore
certains multi cuiseurs à fermer même
remplacé plusieurs appareils qu un
engouement incroyable pour les multiples
usages
notre expert frédéric chabot chef et
spécialiste des techniques de cuisson
tests quatre multi cuiseur qui
représente bien le marché comme il
s'agit d'appareils complexe nous avons
opté pour un petit échantillonnage de
façon à bien comprendre leur
fonctionnement
ricardo instanz viva tefal rapide pau
brevets fasts lowepro examinons d'abord
la technologie de ces appareils c'est
tout simplement une cuve avec un élément
chauffant c'est tout la différence c'est
que j'ai un couvercle fermé de façon
hermétique donc à passer autrement que
c'est fermé hermétiquement je peux
monter la pression d'un comme les
anciens presto et plus la pression monte
plus la température augmente elle peut
atteindre jusqu'à 100 18 degrés celsius
selon l'appareil le principal argument
de vente de ces appareils et la rapidité
de la cuisson apprécions faut pas
oublier aussi c'est que pour atteindre
pression le ça va prendre du temps
donc faut quelqu'un aussi le temps de
créer la pression à l'intérieur
à cela il faut ajouter le temps de
dépressurisation des appareils plus j'ai
d'aliments et de pression dans la cuve
plus ça va prendre du temps à
dépressurisée ça peut prendre jusqu'à
une heure mais alors gagne-t-on vraiment
du temps ça dépend peu des aliments des
préparations mais c'est pas toujours le
cas
toutes les cuissons en body noir dans un
chaudron normal et pas vraiment
davantage à le faire dans un multi
cuisant avec le temps de montée de
pression de
dépressurisation s'apprend grosso modo
le même temps j'ai fait des tests de
cuisson longue comme les mijotés les
bouillons pour le tout beaucoup fait
dans un chaudron ou fourre tout
doucement à 2 190 degrés j'aurais pu
mettre à 350 pour que ça aille plus vite
mais les meilleurs résultats sont
températures plus basses en bo3 ça ça
m'a pris deux heures de cuisson si je
regarde juste le tas cuisson avec même
la pressurisation la dépressurisation
dans le multi cuiseur ce après plus
autour d'une heure donc c'est plus
rapide
le ricardo et le in stone potes ont des
programmes particuliers comme la
fonction nieuwbourg sap est avantageux
parce que le you go doit vraiment se
tenir une température basse et constante
pendant plusieurs heures ce qui est un
peu plus difficile à réaliser sur le
poêle ou même vous faut ou encore
aliments pour bébés je prédis la
fonction légumes aussi ou cuir des pois
chiches dans un multi cuisant c'est plus
rapide mais le programme légumineuses
est trop floue de la vie de notre expert
sur une lentille ou en cuir une fève de
soyaux suppression c'est pas le même
temps du tout qu'est ce que ça donne
d'abord ces programmes là la grande
difficulté de ces appareils est
justement qu'il demande à l'utilisateur
une bonne période d'apprentissage comme
on ne voit pas à l'intérieur on ne sait
pas si l'aliment est trop ou pas assez
cuit avant que tout le cycle se termine
naturellement après un certain temps on
doit s'habituer le ricardo est celui qui
chauffe le plus rapidement son panneau
de contrôle est assez simple mais
attention à ses pieds glissant et il ne
fait pas la fonction mijoteuse
le principal intérêt du in stone potes
et que la compagnie est la référence
dans le marché avec plusieurs modèles et
une immense communauté d'utilisateurs le
in stone potes et très tard parce qu'il
ya vraiment une multitude de recettes
qui ont été développés par l'entreprise
même par des auteurs par des internautes
que plein plein plein de recettes et les
appareils où il faut vraiment ouvrir la
valve à la main alors bien sûr qu'il
faut faire attention parce que je dois
par des cons louve
donc faut se protéger la main sur le thé
fall sur la poignée du couvercle qui ont
ajouté un petit bouton à distance qui
permet de lever la valve pour faire
sortir la vapeur
lebreux ville est de loin le plus cher
mais il est de l'avis de frédéric le
meilleur du lot les appareils sont moins
chers et ont tous un peu chacun leurs
qualités mais on est des fous qui font
qu'en bout de ligne je serai pas tenter
de les acheter c'est que le brevet est
vraiment un panneau de contrôle avec des
informations claires nettes et précises
et aussi ça me permet de suivre le
processus de cuisson jeu peut programmer
le type de dépressurisation que je veux
et l'appareil s'en charge
j'ai pas être à côté de l'appareil quand
ma cuisson est terminée il ya un petit
mécanisme qui va faire que laval
retrouverez et va laisser échapper la
zapa
finalement ces appareils vont-ils nous
faciliter la vie
ce que je trouve inquiétant c'est que
les gens qui aiment pas cuisiner vont
peut-être être attiré par toutes les
fonctions du autres contrôles parce
qu'ils s'imaginent que peut-être que je
veux sa pesée il falloir se faire seul
non c'est pas vrai donc il va y avoir
beaucoup de ses erreurs il mort death ou
piratés il va avoir des produits sous
quid du produit des produits circuit
c'est sûr et certain après un certain
temps on risque d habitude mais
ils s'attendent à mai mois où ça prend
des notes faut écrire nous recettes